(upbeat techno music)
- My name is Ann Thrupp
and I'm the Executive Director
of the Berkeley Food
Institute here on campus
which is a multi-disciplinary
center at UC Berkeley
that is undertaking innovative
research, education,
policy work and community
engagement activities
aimed for transformative
change in food systems.
Along with the graduate division
and the graduate council
of the academic senate,
I'm very honored and delighted to welcome
Dr. Marion Nestle, this year's speaker
in the Barbara Weinstock
Lectures on the Morals of Trade.
Before introducing Dr. Nestle,
I'd like to take a moment to tell you
how the endowment
supporting these lectures
came to UC Berkeley.
In 1902, Harris Weinstock,
a well-known businessman
based in Sacramento,
provided the University
of California with a fund
in honor of his wife,
Barbara, to support an annual
public lecture on the morals of trade.
Weinstock explained his
motivations in an article
written after the first
lecture was delivered in 1904:
"Thus, hope is in the air,
"and there is a better
and cleaner day in store
"for all destined to spend their lives
"in commercial pursuits.
"The thing to do at this hour
"is to accelerate the movement
"and to bring this hoped-for day
"as near to our own as possible.
"The California University Lectureship
"on the Morals of Trade is a small effort
"in that direction."
So others who have
delivered Weinstock lectures
include consumer advocate Ralph Nader,
a member of the British
Parliament Neil Kinnock,
Nobel Laureate Amartya Sen,
former US Secretary of Labor Robert Reich,
and former Secretary of the US Department
of Health and Human
Services Kathleen Sebelius,
so following a very steemed footsteps.
So now I'm very pleased to say a few words
about today's distinguished speaker.
Dr. Marion Nestle is renowned for her work
on nutrition, food
policy and public health,
as many of you probably know.
Her research and writing are widely-read
by both popular and academic audiences.
She examines scientific and
socio-economic dimensions
of food choices, obesity, and food safety
with a focus on the
role of food marketing.
She is a prolific writer.
Several of her award-winning
publications include
Food Politics, Safe Food, What to Eat,
Eat, Drink, Vote, and Soda Politics.
She is also the author
of two books on pet food,
Feed your Pet Right,
and Pet Food Politics.
I bet some of you didn't know that.
From 2008 to 2013, she
contributed a monthly Food Matters
column for the San Francisco
Chronicle food section,
and she blogs almost daily
at www.foodpolitics.com.
So, also, Marion Nestle
earned her BA in Bacteriology,
her Doctorate in Molecular Biology,
and Masters in Public Health and Nutrition
all from UC Berkeley.
So she is undoubtedly a CAL bear,
and this is a special homecoming, I think.
We're also delighted that
she was able to come.
She is currently the Paulette Goddard
Professor of Nutrition, Food Studies,
and Public Health at New York University,
the department she
chaired from 1988 to 2003.
She's also professor of
Sociology at New York University
and Visiting Professor
at Cornell University.
From 1986 through 1988,
she served as a senior
nutrition policy adviser
in the Department of
Health and Human Services
and the editor of the 1988
Surgeon General's Report
on Nutrition and Health.
Dr. Nestle has received
numerous awards and honors.
In 2011, Berkeley School of Public Health
named her Public Health Hero.
Michael Pollan ranked her the number two
Most Powerful Foodie in
America after Michelle Obama,
and Mark Bittman ranked her number one
in his list of foodies to be thankful for.
Yey!
In 2013, she received the
James Beard Leadership Award
and in 2014, the US
Healthful Food Council's
Innovator for the Year Award,
and the Public Heath Association
New York City Media Award.
In 2016, her book Soda
Politics won literary awards
from the James Beard Foundation,
and the International Association
of Culinary Professionals.
I'd like to add more
personally that Marion's work
is a tremendous inspiration to thousands
and thousands of people.
She is a great hero for many of us
affiliated with the
Berkeley Food Institute
and the UC Berkeley
community far more widely.
In her lecture today,
Dr. Nestle will address
cultural, economic and
institutional factors
that influence food policies and choices
and the balance between
individual, societal
responsibility for these
choices, and much more.
I'm sure you will be enthralled.
Please join me in welcoming Marion Nestle
back to UC Berkeley.
(clapping)
- Thank you, Ann, for that
incredibly embarrassing introduction.
And thank you all for coming
on this absolutely beautiful day.
I'm thrilled to be here
to give this lecture.
I have to say that when
I was invited to give it,
my initial reaction was,
"What does what I do
"have to do with the morals of trade?"
And I'm going to start by
trying to explain that.
I think I figured it out.
First of all, I had some help.
Steve Lubin who was
someone who was connected
to the Weinstock Lubin family
sent me a whole lot of
information about it
and told me that Harris Weinstock
had something to do with
Industrial Relations Commission
and was Market Director in
California in the early 1900s
and his half brother,
David Lubin, founded the
International Institute
of Agriculture in Rome.
Together they owned a vineyard,
they owned wheat land,
they promoted cooperatives,
gave speeches about
trade and tariff issues,
and did a lot of observations
of European agriculture.
So, that's a connection that I couldn't
find out anything about Barbara Weinstock.
She apparently did not
have her own identity,
and that's a worry.
I'd like to know more about her.
The morals of trade was a really big issue
in the 1870s to early 1900s.
There were books written
about the sins of trade
and the morals of the way the trade policy
affected society, and some of that
comes right up to the present time.
The easiest analogy is fair trade
where there are now books about fair trade
and lots and lots going on with that,
so that the fair trade movement,
which is the connection
between these old ideas
about morals of trade and
the kind of work that I do
about the 21st century food movement,
fair trade is about making
sure that the producers
get sufficient money for
the work that they do,
that there is no child or forced labor,
that there's no discrimination
as gender equity,
there is capacity-building,
and there's a lot of concern
about the environmental impact
of what people are doing.
These are all part of
today's food movement.
But I wanna start this,
from work of Kate Clancy in 1982.
Kate Clancy was a doctoral graduate of the
I think the Nutritional
Science Program here,
and in 1982, she wrote
a paper that, for me,
was absolutely life-changing.
She asked a question that I didn't think
anybody had ever asked before.
"Is it moral, is it ethical
"for food companies to
make and profit from
"highly processed foods
of low nutritional value,
"what we rudely called junk foods?
"Is it moral to urge people
to consume such foods?
"Is it moral to market
such foods for children?"
This, I have to say, changed
the way I thought about
the whole issue of food
choice and food production.
And if bringing that right up to 2017,
I wanna add a few questions to that.
Is it moral to sell and market
ultra-processed junk foods?
That question still exists.
To support unhealthful,
inequitable food environments?
To market junk foods
in developing economies
where people certainly don't need them?
To work as hard as they possible can
to oppose any public health effort
to improve dietary intake?
To spy on public health advocates?
To fund health organizations
to buy their silence
around food issues?
Or to fund research to
promote and protect sales
of products, which is
the subject of the book
I'm working on now.
I think these questions are
really important to ask.
And they're questions that
drive the food movement.
And I approached these questions from
what is called these days food systems.
Food systems has a lot of meanings
for a lot of different people.
I'm gonna give you my version of it,
which is everything about food
production and consumption
from science to agricultural production,
to nutrition, to public
health and to food advocacy
for a healthier and more
sustainable food system.
It's just the big picture.
I'm interested in the big
picture because I think
the most important public health problems
that face the world today
have to do with food issues.
Most important in the sense of the number
of people that they affect.
Food, obviously, affects
everyone, everyone eats.
So, the three big problems
are food insecurity,
not having enough food
to meet daily needs,
obesity and its personal and
public health consequences,
and the environmental
impact of our food choices.
Let me just say a little
bit about each of those
to get us started on this.
The Food and Agriculture
Organization of the United Nations
says that about 800
million people in the world
do not have enough food on a daily basis
to meet their needs.
That is great news because it represents
a decline of 200 million since 1990.
If you believe the figures
and there's some question
about whether these figures are accurate
or whether they represent
the result of a change
in the way the counting was done,
whatever it is, there are a lot of people
who don't have enough food.
There are people like
that in the United States
and there are plenty of people like that
throughout the world.
It's a huge problem.
At the same time, there are
probably two billion people
who are overweight to the
point where they've developed
risks or have symptoms of chronic diseases
such as Type II Diabetes,
heart disease and so forth,
and what is remarkable
about the obesity issue
is that it's a worldwide phenomenon,
and men and women all over the world,
in every area of the
world, particularly Asia,
Southeast Asia, southern
Europe and Latin America,
are gaining weight, developing
symptoms of Type II Diabetes
in countries that do not have the capacity
to help them with treatment.
It would be much better
if they could present it,
if they could prevent those conditions.
And what joins the two has to
do with socio-economic status
and inequity in income,
education and resources.
This article talked about the growing
socio-economic disparity
in dietary quality
that leads to both under-nutrition
and over-nutrition,
and this was a relatively recent article
from just a few years
ago, but the first time
that I saw anything about that
was in the New York Times
magazine in 1996, 20 years ago,
which had a cover story on
how we eat in America divided.
And it talked about how
different the diets were
of people who are educated and had money
and people who didn't have money
and didn't have resources,
so that dietary quality
was not only a matter of personal choice,
it was also a matter of social
class and the environment.
Very important concept
in trying to figure out
how we're going to deal with these issues.
The third aspect of the food system that
is a worldwide phenomenon is the effect
of agricultural production
on greenhouse gas emissions,
and this is one view of it.
I don't wanna push this too hard
because I'm not sure
what the exact figure is.
There are estimates from
10% of greenhouse gases
to 25 or 30% of greenhouse gases
due to the way we produce food.
Whatever it is, it's a big chunk
of greenhouse gas emissions
and if we had a better
and more sustainable way
of producing food, we
would be helping to prevent
the climate change that seems
to be happening so rapidly.
Our food choices also
affect climate change,
and this is an estimation of the effect
of our dietary choices on
greenhouse gas emissions
and what it shows is
that red meat production
and consumption are the
single greatest contributors
to greenhouse gases from the foods we eat.
Animal foods in general are 60%
of greenhouse gas emissions,
another 25% from processed foods,
and the ones that are
the lowest are fruits
and vegetables and grains, just the foods
that nutritionists are
always telling you to eat,
a point that I will come back to.
So, what do we do about this?
Well, Michael Pollan,
who's on this faculty,
it is so simple to tell people what to eat
that he could do it in seven words.
And really, they work.
Eat food, not too much, mostly plants,
a really terrific way of putting it.
By food, he means real foods
that are relatively unprocessed.
I have a slightly more
complicated way of putting it.
If you're worried about obesity,
you need to make better food choices,
you have to eat less,
and you need to move more
and, please don't eat my book.
But if it seems more
complicated than this,
it's because of the effect
of this kind of advice
on the food system.
The Dietary Guidelines for Americans
that came out last year
or the year before,
the 2015-2020 Dietary Guidelines,
basically say the same
things as Michael Pollan did,
to eat more fruits and
vegetables and grains
and whole foods, and eat
less processed foods,
ultra-processed junk foods,
whatever you wanna call them.
But the problem is, and
it's a huge problem,
is that the profits of the food industry
are in the junk foods.
That's where the money is.
And so there are huge economic forces
that are operating against
trying to eat more healthfully.
And those economic forces are
very difficult to deal with.
For one thing, they advertise,
and there's a reason why so
much of the food industry's
advertising dollars go
into processed foods
rather than go into fruits and vegetable.
Virtually nothing goes
into fruits and vegetables
but the numbers that I'm
showing on this slide
are numbers that are
really hard to come by.
And these are individual
advertising budgets
for specific food products.
I think the number $30 billion,
which is food, beverage
and restaurant advertising
is too big to understand,
but you can understand $30 million annual
advertising budget for pop tarts
just in the United States,
$110 million for M&Ms,
$148 million for Reese's
peanut butter cups,
that might have something to
do with why you like them,
and $254 million just
for classic Coca-Cola,
not any of the other
products that they do.
These are staggering amounts of money
in public health terms.
No public health agency
has this kind of money
to work on public
education or anything else.
And the government
supports this kind of thing
by allowing food marketing
to be a business expense
and deductible from corporate taxes.
That's something to think about.
Another thing the food industry did
was to make larger portions.
They did that because policies
that encourage farmers to grow more food,
this happened in the 1970s and early '80s,
but today, the restaurant
portions are four times
what they were in 1950,
and they're probably two
or three times higher
than they were in 1980.
And if I had one thing that I could teach
the American public and
entire world about nutrition,
it would be this: larger
portions have more calories.
(audience laughing)
This is so not intuitively obvious
that it really is born and
I think that larger portions
are a sufficient explanation
for why people began
to gain weight in the early 1980s.
Portions got bigger, bagels got bigger,
sodas got bigger, everything got bigger,
people got bigger.
Pretty easy to understand.
Another critically important point
that bears on the
policies and, if you like,
the morals of the policies
that we're talking about
and that has to do with the
relative changing prices
between 1980, which is
the start of the rise
in the problems of obesity,
and the present time.
The slide may be hard to read
but the line in the middle of it
is the relative increase
in price that occurred
in the entire food system.
What you can see is fresh
fruits and vegetables
and processed foods and vegetables,
their prices increased at
a much, much higher rate
than the prices of, for
example, sugars and fats
which we're supposed to eat less of,
and soft drinks which I wrote
a book about eating less of.
So, this is, I think, the
result of federal policies
that allow the prices of some foods
to be higher than others,
and this is a complicated issue,
but if poor people think
that fruits and vegetables
are expensive, it's because they are.
And so we have a system
in which the government,
in conjunction with the food industry,
have created an environment
that encourages people
to eat more, and to eat more
of the wrong kinds of foods.
So if that's how our policy
has led, then we change policy.
And a couple of years ago,
Mark Bittman, Michael Pollan,
Ricardo Salvador and Olivier De Schutter
wrote a document for the Washington Post
about how a national food policy is needed
and could save millions of American lives.
It's a very interesting article to read
and had lots and lots of
advice about things to do,
but I think it missed
a very important point.
And it's a point that I wanna talk about,
which is that in the United States,
we have food policies
but they are divided.
We have a food policy that
deals with consumption,
that's nutrition policy,
and a food policy that
deals with production,
that's agricultural policy,
the Farm Bill and so forth,
and these have nothing
whatsoever to do with each other.
And I think this is a
very, very serious problem
in our country, and one
that needs to be fixed.
So, let me introduce this
by asking a question.
In the United States Nutrition Policy,
where is agriculture?
United States Nutrition
Policy is expressed
in the Dietary Guidelines for Americans,
which is a document produced
by the Department of Agriculture
and Health and Human Services since 1980.
It comes out every five
years by order of Congress
and this is the panoply
of examples since 1980.
The most recent one, as I
said before, came out in 2015,
actually came out early in 2016.
So, the dietary guidelines are organized.
The way they are currently done is
academic community gets together
and reviews the literature
and writes a research document that
in the case of this one, was 600 pages.
And in that document,
the Dietary Guidelines
Advisory Committee made this statement
that a diet that had more plant foods
and fewer animal foods
will promote health more
and will be less
environmentally unfriendly
than the current U.S. diet.
Something that you would
think that everybody
could pretty much agree on.
The meat industry didn't like it.
They didn't like it a lot.
They viewed the Dietary
Guidelines Advisory Committee
report as an attack on the meat industry
and the reacted just the
way you would think that
a meat industry that was
being attacked would react.
And they went straight to Congress.
That's how the food
industry works these days.
If they don't like what
the agencies are doing,
they go to Congress.
And Congress, in its infinite wisdom,
put into a House Agricultural
Appropriations Bill
a statement that the Advisory Committee
for the Dietary Guidelines
is behaving in a very unpleasant way,
it's interested in
sustainability, climate change
and other things that we would rather
that they did not talk about,
and we expect the Secretary of Agriculture
to make sure that not one word of this
gets into the Dietary Guidelines.
And that's, in fact, what happened.
Secretary Tom Vilsack, in March 2015,
six months before the Dietary
Guidelines were released,
made the statement that
sustainability issues
fall outside the scope of
the Dietary Guidelines,
and when the Dietary
Guidelines were released
six months later, the word sustainability
does not appear anywhere in the document
in its 144 pages, searchable.
You will not find that word.
So, so much for agriculture
as part of nutrition policy.
The Dietary Guidelines
Committee tried, they failed.
What about agriculture
policy considering nutrition,
obesity, over-consumption
and any of the other
kinds of things that
we're concerned about?
Well, this brings us to the Farm Bill
and the Berkeley Food Institute
is having a meeting in
Washington next week
in which they're going to be
talking about the Farm Bill.
It will be fascinating to
see what they talk about
and what they think is going to happen
in the present administration.
But I can tell you what
the last administration
thought about it.
President Obama said
of the 2014 Farm Bill,
"It's like a Swiss Army knife."
I don't know exactly what he meant by that
but what I think he means
is it does a lot of things
but it doesn't do any of them very well.
(audience laughing)
So, the Farm Bill, what can
we say about the Farm Bill?
U.S. agriculture policy,
does it say anything about nutrition?
Yes, it does.
The Department of Agriculture came out
with the My Plate food guide,
and that says very clearly,
"Make half your plate
fruits and vegetables."
Half you plate, fruits and vegetables.
Okay, so what else does the
Department of Agriculture do?
Well, we have Representative
Chellie Pingree from Maine
to thank for this particular
document which covered
the agricultural subsidies
from the Farm Bill
of 2008, from 2008 to 2012,
and what it showed was
that 0.45%, less than a half of percent
of the total agricultural
money that was spent
on farm supports of any kind
went to fruits and vegetables.
The rest of it went to corn, soybeans,
oils, cotton, and so forth.
Even more of a percentage went to tobacco
than went to fruits and vegetables.
So there's a big disconnect
between parts of the
Department of Agriculture
and nutrition is not part
of agricultural policy.
It absolutely should be, and I hope, Ann,
that you will make sure that
that conference says so.
So given this situation, what
is the poor consumer to do?
If people are consumed about
what they're supposed to be eating,
it's because they're
getting very mixed messages,
from government, from
nutritionists, from everybody.
And trying to figure
out your way to navigate
this kind of food landscape
is extremely difficult
and the solution to it is,
(audience laughing)
you gotta start eating out
of a different parking lot.
And what that means is
changing the food environment
so that it promotes healthier eating.
And I wanna talk a little bit about that.
There's a new advocacy organization called
Plate of the Union, that
came out just a few weeks ago
with a proposal for the
Farm Bill that we emphasize
more organic food, we
invest in healthy farms,
we fight hunger and food insecurity,
and revitalize the land,
and reduce food waste.
Reducing food waste is
probably the easiest of those,
which is why there is
so much interest in it.
But I think there are other
food movement policies as well
that are important to look at.
And this is a slide I've
used for a long time.
Looking at the various
aspects of the food movement
all done in revolutionary
terms as slow food revolution,
the organic revolution, the
local (mumbles) movement,
and even the occupy
movement, are all parts of a
enormous collection of
groups that are working
to try to make diets healthier
and more sustainable.
I wrote a book about food
advocacy called Soda Politics
that came out two years
ago, and a lot of it
was about how you advocate
for healthier diets
using sodas as an example.
And I subtitled the book
Taking on Big Soda and winning
because I think that the
soft drinks story is one
where advocates have
had a very big impact.
And the impact is easiest
to see in sales of sugar,
sweet and beverages, which
peaked in the late 1990s
and have been going down
steadily ever since.
And this year was the
first year in which sales
of bottled water exceeded sales of sugar,
sweet and beverages Coke and Pepsi.
Whether we all ought to be
drinking water in bottles
is another story.
Let's save that for another talk.
From the standpoint of
the soft drink industry,
this has been enormous disruption.
They think it's due to health advocacy.
I'm not going to argue
with them about that.
Now, the reason for focusing
on sugar, sweet and beverages
is that they provide roughly half
of the sugars in the American diet.
And the amount of sugar
that's in soft drinks
is absolutely staggering.
You can't see it, you can't taste it,
you don't realize it's there
but there's really a lot.
The Dietary Guidelines for Americans
and the World Health
Organization both advise
having no more than 10%
of your daily calories
from added sugars.
To give you an idea of how little that is,
10% of calories, I've
shown here a 16-ounce
soft drink or Coca-Cola.
This is the size that Mayor Bloomberg
wanted to cap sodas at
and it contains about 180
calories and 49 grams of sugar.
If you have a 2,000-calorie a day diet,
you're allowed 50 grams of sugar a day.
One 16-ounce soda has 49 grams.
So this is a big cut back in sugar.
It's another reason why soft
drinks are such a easy target
because they have so much sugar in them.
Sugar has no nutrients, whatever.
So the soft drink industry has been under
extraordinary scrutiny lately,
scrutiny for its business
practices as this
Bloomberg Business Week
slightly offensive cover showed,
scrutiny for its practices
in marketing to children.
The major soda companies
have said that they will not
market to children under the age of 12
on television programs aimed at children
under the age of 12.
This sounds great but if you
think about it for two seconds,
you realize that there
are many, many loopholes
in that kind of marketing,
and every group that has tried
to evaluate whether soft
drinks are, in fact,
marketing to children under the age of 12
finds that they are in many other ways
as this Sugary Drink FACTS
report from the Rudd Center
in Connecticut came out and said.
The soft drink companies
are also under scrutiny
for marketing to minorities,
which is something
that there's a long history about,
but minority groups are
the largest consumers
of sugar, sweet and beverages,
and that's where the
marketing effort is going.
I mentioned Bloomberg's soda cap idea
because it's another place
where ethical issues come in
and where the question is, is it ethical
for food companies to fight
public health measures?
So here was Bloomberg
who wanted to put a cap
on the size of sodas sold in
New York City at 16 ounces,
and the soda industry
went absolutely ballistic
and eventually took the city to court,
won the suit, and ended
that whole enterprise.
I'm not gonna say too much about that
because I don't think that
the Bloomberg administration
handled it very well.
And there's a chapter
in my book that explains
what they didn't do that they should have.
But the fact the soda
industry fought so hard
and spent untold millions of
dollars to fight the soda cap
is one of those questions that
raises a moral and ethical
issue in the context of
what we're talking about.
These issues also came up in the context
of the New York Times
revelations in August 2015
that Coca-Cola had been
funding a group of researchers
on obesity to argue that physical activity
was the problem with gaining weight,
it really didn't have anything
to do with what you ate.
And this was so incredible
and raised such questions of incredulity
that even Fox News was
shocked as shown here.
It was pretty shocking
and the reaction to it
was incredulous, I don't
know how else to put it.
And Coca-Cola got a lot of
pushback for this revelation,
so much of a pushback that a week later,
the head of Coca-Cola
International, Muhtar Kent
wrote an Op-Ed for the Wall Street Journal
in which he said, "We've
been caught in something
"we didn't even realize we were doing.
"We can do better than this.
"This doesn't reflect our company.
"We are making a commitment
to publicly disclose
"everybody that we fund,
"and it was gonna take a while to do that
"because we're gonna ask
everybody if they mind
"if we tell, and some people did."
They would rather not know that,
but, in fact, they did exactly
what they were going to do
and they published on their website
and it is still on their website
and it is still fascinating reading.
They published a list
of the 1,200 individuals
and organizations that Coca-Cola funds,
I think for the purpose of
buying silence, if nothing else.
And they published a list of
individual health professionals
who consulted for or
otherwise paid by Coca-Cola.
And a group called the Ninjas for Health,
they're quite something,
did an analysis of it
and discovered that 55%
of individuals who were taking money
from Coca-Cola were dieticians.
So, Coco knew what it
was doing in that sense.
The revelations of who got
funded had a big fallout.
For one thing, a lot of the
groups were very embarrassed.
The Academy of Nutrition and Dietetics,
the American Academy of Pediatrics,
and the American Academy
of Family Practice
were all organizations
with substantial opposition
among their membership to collaborating
and partnering with Coca-Cola,
and Coca-Cola pulled out of
those three organizations.
Soon after that, the
University of Colorado,
which was the place where this
Global Energy Balance Network was located
returned a million-dollar
grant to Coca-Cola.
Those of you who know anything
about university funding,
that should bring a
gasp, that the university
would give back a million
dollars, are you kidding?
But the University of
Colorado was so embarrassed
by the way this money appeared
that they gave it back.
And then Coca-Cola eventually pulled out
of the Global Energy Balance Network
and that was the end of that,
or almost the end of that,
because what happened next
was that reporters started
using open records requests
and getting emails from the researchers
who were taking money from Coca-Cola.
I'm very happy to be working
at a private university
so my email is not FOIable,
but if you're at Berkeley,
yours is, be careful,
that's all I can say.
So the Associated Press
was the first to publish
about the emails between
Coca-Cola executives
and these researchers, and
they quoted Rhona Applebaum
who was then the Chief
Scientific Officer at Coca-Cola,
talking about how the Global
Energy Balance Network
at Colorado was a weapon in their fight
against radical organizations
and their proponents.
I guess they mean by that, people like me
who were thinking that soda taxes
really weren't such a terrible idea.
In any case, on the day
that the Associated Press
published the article about
these emails, she resigned.
What a coincidence.
Then Coca-Cola, and I think not because
they were trying to
hide the amount of money
they were spending, but I
think they really didn't know
how much money they were spending,
found out that they were
spending a lot more,
they now report that they've
spent about $135 million
to support research and
partnerships with organizations
of one kind or another,
and their partnerships
tend to be with health organizations
and fitness organizations,
some of them quite amazing.
I don't think we've seen
the end of that yet.
The Coca-Cola-sponsored
research tends to come out
with results that are very
favorable to Coca-Cola.
This is typical of industry-funded
research, generally.
So here are three examples.
The National Health and
Nutrition Examinations Survey,
which is the main survey that
shows that sugary soft drinks
are linked to obesity
and diabetes, that survey
has no validity according to
this study funded by Coca-Cola.
Any results in the
literature that indicate
a link between sodas and
obesity have no validity,
according to a Coca-Cola-funded study,
and sugars are harmless,
according to another
Coca-Cola-funded study.
And in fact, this kind
of thing is so common
that a group of investigators
at the end of last year
published an article and an analysis
in the Annals of Internal Medicine
in which they asked the question,
are sugary drinks related
to obesity and diabetes?
And they counted up the studies
that went one way or the other
and they found 26 studies that said no,
sugary drinks have
nothing whatsoever to do
with obesity and diabetes.
Every single one of them was
funded either by Coca-Cola
or the American Beverage Association
or some other industry
that they work with.
On the other hand, there were
34 studies that said yes,
sugary drinks are related
to obesity and diabetes,
and of those, only one
was funded by industry.
I bet that person never got more money.
(audience laughing)
So if you can't sell sodas
in the United States,
sell them overseas.
And what's remarkable about
the effort of Coca-Cola,
in particular, to sell Coca-Cola overseas
is the amount of money
that it has committed,
but I can tell you that Pepsi Cola
has committed equivalent amounts.
Center for Science in the Public Interest
came out with a report last year
in which they added
this up in this diagram.
It comes from their report,
and between the numbers, refer usually to
a 10-year period from 2010 to 2020,
Coca-Cola is investing
$12.4 billions in Mexico.
$17 billion dollars, that's a B, not an M,
billion in Africa during that period.
And if you just think about
what $17 billion could do
for development in Africa,
then the idea of building bottling plants
and arranging for people
to be selling Coca-Cola
seems ethically questionable.
Is that a fair statement?
The other thing that
came up, I'm just back
from a Fulbright in Mexico at
the Institute of Public Health
where these people were still reeling
from having spyware
installed on their phones.
And this is spyware that
was invented in Israel
to trace terrorists, and it
is sold only to governments,
only to governments, and that must mean
that somebody in the Mexican government
authorized the installation
of this spyware
on these people's phones.
These are soda tax advocates.
On the left is Simon
Barquera who works at the
Institute of Public Health in Cuernavaca
and is doing research on sodas in Mexico
or big problem in Mexico.
Mexico drinks a lot of soda
and they have very high rates of obesity.
And on the right is Alejandro Calvillo
who's the head of the
leading advocacy organization
that is fighting for the soda tax.
The units with which they work
have Bloomberg philanthropy money
so they're rather well-funded
for doing their work
and they've been
extraordinarily effective,
and they have spyware
installed on their phones.
When you talk to them, they
collect everybody's phones
and put them in the refrigerator,
so that they're not being listened to.
I was spied on when the
revelations came out
about the leaks of the emails
that came out from Hillary CLinton's,
people that worked on
Hillary Clinton's campaign,
there was a separate set of emails
that was posted on DC Leaks
and they're still there,
you can go look at them, because somebody
who worked on the Hillary Clinton campaign
also was consulting for
Coca-Cola at the same time.
So by coincidence, when the Russians,
I guess it was the Russians,
picked up all these
emails and posted them,
there was a collection
of Coca-Cola emails, too.
And I got very quick
messages from people saying,
"Marion, you're in the emails."
(audience laughing)
I was so excited.
I was in Australia in
the winter a year ago
in the early 2016, and
Coca-Cola sent somebody
to a lecture that I gave at
the University of Sydney.
I was talking about soda
politics which had just come out
and took notes, and those
notes were passed up
the chain of command and ended up
in Capricia Marshall's email cache
and are now posted for everybody to see.
And what they recommended was that my
activities in Australia be monitored.
I knew that somebody at my
talk was from Coca-Cola.
I assume that there's
somebody from Coca-Cola
at every talk I give.
Hi.
(audience laughing)
So I wasn't particularly
concerned about it.
I was just amused by this,
but the Sydney Morning Herald
did a big article about
Coca-Cola's secret plan
to monitor the woman whose
group I was working with
in Australia, Lisa Bero, who
works on conflicts of interest.
So that was kind of exciting,
not as exciting as spyware
but exciting, nevertheless.
So this is the kind of thing
that the food industry does,
it's just that Coca-Cola got exposed.
But my assumption is that
this is what big food companies do.
And Michael Pollan wrote last year
in The New York Times
magazine about the Obamas,
that whenever they did anything
serious about big food,
they were quickly outlobbied and outgunned
and then he said, "The food
movement still barely exists
"as a political force."
I'm not sure that's true.
I tend to be maybe more
optimistic than he is.
And so I wanna talk about
why I think the food movement
is really making progress,
and I'll just say personally
I measure it by food studies
programs at universities.
When we at NYU started our
Food Studies Program in 1996,
we were it and everybody
thought we were crazy.
Who would ever wanna study about food?
20 years later, we have
all of you in the audience,
the Berkeley Food Institute,
Jen and your chancellor's
enormous food program,
and almost every university that I visit
has a food studies program
of one kind or other.
So that's my personal measure of it.
But there are other
ways to measure it, too.
The increase in the
number of farmers market
shown on the left,
and the increase in organic
sales shown on the right.
These are measurable,
quantifiable demonstrations
of the effectiveness of the food movement.
The fight for a minimum
wage, the fight for 15,
(mumbles) is on the faculty
of the Goldman School
has been heading up this,
and is one of the leaders
in this movement.
It, too, is having enormous success,
not as much as we'd
like, but still success,
and there are many, many people
who are participating in that.
The food industry is listening.
Sometimes they listen in
superficial and cosmetic ways,
like taking aspartame or additives,
or artificial colors or dyes out of foods.
That's nice but it's not world-shaking.
Sometimes it's in more
important ways, like sourcing
animals that were not
treated with antibiotics.
That one is much more important.
So the food industry is listening.
And, of course, there are soda taxes.
With Berkeley leading the way,
with an advocacy campaign for soda tax
that was absolutely exemplary,
done advocacy by the book
exactly the way it's supposed to be done,
and it was no wonder that
it passed with a 76% vote,
and set an example for
lots of other cities
that are following this example,
and there's a soda tax movement
that is now taking place
throughout the United States.
Here's the current list.
The one that's in play
right now is Santa Fe,
but all of these others have passed taxes
and often with really
impressive majorities.
It's also one of the things
about the tax movement
that I think is really important
is its being framed as
a social justice issue,
that people will be healthier
if they're not drinking these things,
if they don't have corporations running
what they're supposed to
be eating in their life.
Social justice, moral, ethical, just what
we're supposed to be talking about here.
It's also a trade issue because soda tax
has become a worldwide phenomenon.
South Africa, Portugal
and the United Kingdom
are either looking at or
have passed soda taxes
and so our trading partners
are getting involved in this
and of course, the most
impressive one is Mexico
where I just was, where
the advocacy campaign
has been carried out at
the highest possible level,
and the research that goes with it is also
being done at the highest possible level,
and they've just come out with a paper
that documents a significant
reduction in soda consumption,
particularly among people who are poor,
which is exactly the target group
that they wanted to get at.
So, much, much progress,
signs of movements,
and then the business community thinks
that food activists are
your new brand managers.
Let's make that true,
would be my recommendation here.
So the food industry is scared,
they're worried about it,
and it's up to us to make sure
that we hold them accountable.
So that brings me to
the moral of the story
which is that I think
it's really important
for us to exercise our personal moral
and ethical responsibility
in our food choices.
That's Vote With Your Fork every time
you make a decision about the
kind of food you're buying,
you're making a vote for
the kind of food system
that you want to have.
Make it happen, choose fair trade,
and choose all of these
other kinds of foods
that will be healthier for
people and for the environment.
At the same time, I think we
have a moral responsibility
as a society to change
food system policies.
I think that's going to be
difficult for the next few years,
but that doesn't mean that
we shouldn't be trying,
and it doesn't mean that
we shouldn't be trying
particularly at the local level
where real progress can be made.
The purpose of this is to
make the healthy choice
the easy choice
and the most environmentally
friendly choice.
So that's the message that
I wanna leave you with
and I thank you very, very much
for the opportunity to
share this with you today.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Man] I want you to comment,
I've always been struck with
just how much more expensive
what we call organic
food at the grocery is.
I mean, fruits and vegetables
(mumbles) to start with,
and then on top of that,
is the profit margin
greater on organic food
than it is on regular?
- It may be, you'll have to
ask organic producers here
but it costs more to produce organic food
because you have to use better techniques,
you need more people, you
need people watching it,
you gotta handpick off bugs,
you gotta do all kinds of things,
so it's more expensive.
Is it more profitable?
I think maybe it is, I don't know.
I think it depends,
but it certainly costs more to produce.
Yeah?
- [Man] Hi, thank you
so much for your talk.
I just had a question about the personal
moral responsibility.
It seems like, to me,
we seem wave after wave
of activism changed the
way that the market works
but ultimately, the corporations
that are controlling
most of the capital and the resources
seem to have misaligned incentives
with the rest of society
to create a better way
of life for everyone,
and I'm wondering how you square away
the misaligned incentives of capitalism
that will always co-opt methods
to recycle better, to
treat workers better,
with the individual choice
of making the world a better place.
- Yeah, I think it's very difficult,
it would be very difficult
for me to give a talk
that started out saying I
think our capitalist system
is really bad for health
and the environment.
It's much easier for me
to talk about it this way.
And I think people can hear it better
if you talk about it this way.
I think what the food movement is doing
is trying to create an alternative.
It's a small alternative,
it's not a huge piece of it,
but it's an important piece
for a great many people.
And if you wanna take on
capitalism, more power to you.
I don't know how to do that.
I certainly don't know how to do it now
when half of the voters,
or slightly less than half of the voters
elected somebody who's very
interested in capitalism
and his own self-interests.
So I'd rather talk about this.
I think you can go into a school
and change the food in a school
and make that food healthy.
And people are doing
that all over the country
and you're doing wonderful things
for the kids in that school,
and maybe teaching them
about alternatives.
I don't know any other way of doing it.
I'm not somebody who's
willing to take that on.
- [Man] I really respect that response.
I think one thing I'll
just say to challenge you
is that with survey after survey,
you see that particularly
young people are increasingly
disenfranchised with
capitalism, generally,
and are more open to alternative systems,
not only systematically
but also in the way
that we distribute resources,
so I'd encourage you to
check out those numbers
because I think there
may be a bigger opening
than we like to think,
so, thank you again.
- Well, then, vote.
Get out there and vote.
(audience laughing, clapping)
- [Woman] I am an Redditor-dietician,
I'm not paid by Coke, I promise.
Most of us are not.
And I'm really interested
in the convergence
of nutrition and sustainability.
I think it's really big,
and sometimes when you
talk about more of these,
do you think we'll see it in
the 2020 Dietary Guidelines?
- In this administration?
(audience laughing)
I don't know.
It depends on who the committee is,
how strong the committee is,
and how the committee is willing to fight
for what they think is right.
And I don't know, I
mean, are they appointing
that committee right now?
I don't intend to be appointed
to those committees anymore, so (laughs).
(woman speaking, indistinct)
Yes, so it depends on who gets on there.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- [Woman] Hi, thank you
so much for your talk
and thank you for your work, I love it.
This might be another
sort of knotty problem
linked to capitalism,
but what do you see as
a possible solution or
solutions to the problem
of industry-funded research,
because we see that across
the board in all disciplines
and it's really problematic?
- Yeah, that's the subject of the book
I'm working on right now.
I only see one solution to it
and it's an impossible one.
And that is, and I'll just
go cut right to the chase.
Because industry funding
influences the outcome of research,
and the people who do the research
do not recognize that influence
and are completely
unconscious of its happening,
and there's plenty of
research that shows that,
the only way that you could do that
would be to set up an industry
fund that was required.
I mean, I think if you require
food companies of a
certain size to contribute
a certain amount of money
into a research fund,
then they were required to
do it, it wasn't voluntary.
If it was voluntary, you'd
have to pander to the companies
and that wouldn't work.
Then I thought I think
something like that might work.
But I can't think of
anything less than that.
You know, I think there
are individual researchers
who can try to protect themselves
from the influence, if they're aware
that they might be influenced,
but it's really difficult.
- [Woman] And I think it's great.
Thank you so much.
- [Woman] Hi, I'm wondering
if you have any thoughts
about the proliferation of tech companies
getting in on food and
food delivery services
and what friends of mine
are starting to call
the uberization of food.
That's something you're
watching or thinking about.
- Yeah, I think it's hilarious.
I mean, I'm the wrong
generation for this, right?
And I have sort of an automatic (mumbles).
Have you ever tasted it?
It tastes like uncooked pancake batter
in my view, and you can quote me,
but yeah, I just don't get it at all.
And yet, there are people
who are fascinated by it.
There's vast amounts of
venture capital going into it.
And I actually have gone to
a couple of tech conferences
'cause I'm kinda interested
in what they're doing,
and I did actually visit AeroFarms,
which is a place where
they're growing microgreens
in a huge factory in Newark, New Jersey.
And that's impressive, actually.
So, there may be some
aspects of it that work
but I wouldn't put any money in it.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- [Man] Hi there.
I'm one of the people that
advocates eating insects
in a self-interested way
because I own a company
that farms food-grade crickets,
and we're building a new place in--
- I'm looking horrified
because I was given
an enormous bag of, they weren't crickets,
what were they?
Grasshoppers, yes, which I shared
with people at lunch today.
- [Man] Yeah, and they're
delicious, I think.
And we also try them.
So we're trying to build
a kind of new piece
of the food industry, and most of us
are trying to do that responsibly.
I'd be curious if you had any thoughts
on how to avoid some of the pitfalls
that loom for scaling food businesses
as, you know, we see,
you know, the capitalist
structure of forcing
large companies or
incentivizing large companies
to act in kind of not
very responsible ways.
- Well, you do the best you can,
but economic forces are
invariably to cut costs
'cause cost is the big issue in food.
I've just read this morning, I think,
that retail grocery stores
are having a terrible time.
Wegmans, which is a
chain in the Northeast,
is having to cut its prices
because it can't compete.
So if the pressure is to keep
the price as low as possible,
then you're going to not pay
your workers reasonable wages,
you're going to cut food safety,
you're gonna do all those other things
that food companies are doing.
So, one of the arguments is
well, people need to pay more for food.
That's not an argument
I'm comfortable making
because if we're gonna make
people pay more for food,
we have to pay people more
so they can afford it.
We have enough trouble with that,
so good luck to you.
I don't know what to say.
You have to stay small,
and if you stay small,
then you won't be rich.
(audience laughing)
Well, you know, I was in
academic all my life and it's...
- [Woman] So thank you for a great talk.
I mean, it was fantastic.
But I want to ask just your thoughts,
your broad thoughts on an issue
that didn't come up in the talk
which is the whole foods
all need to be cooked,
whereas everything else
is just handed to you
all fried and buttered and
cut up into bite-size pieces.
And you know, it somehow
seems to have become
harder and harder for small
families, or single people,
or even large families to just cook,
and I just wonder what your thoughts are
on how that can be done
more because I don't see,
that's just a practicality
that we have to think through.
- Yeah, I learned to cook
in junior high school.
You know, home economics,
that I would took cooking classes.
And one of the things, you
know, if you know how to cook,
you can produce a meal in no time at all.
But people have other
priorities and I don't like
to judge other people's
decisions about that.
If they don't want to cook, or
they don't know how to cook,
there are plenty of other options.
If you do know how to cook,
you can live very cheaply.
So that's an incentive.
I don't know what to say about that.
I like to cook sometimes,
but sometimes not.
- [Woman] I, too, wanna thank
you for all your many years
of incredibly important and valuable work.
My question also relates to something
that was not touched on in your talk
but that is your thoughts
on the effectiveness
of food recovery efforts
because of the enormous
amount of wasted food.
- Yeah, I decided that waste
wasn't gonna be my issue
and I would leave it to
lots of other people.
I think it's an easy one,
and it's a feel-good issue,
makes everybody feel really terrific.
I'm much more concerned
about the production side,
that the reason we have
so much waste is because
so much is produced, and
it's built into the system.
And I'd rather try to figure out some way
to attack it from that end.
But lots and lots and lots of people
are involved in food waste in the same way
that lots and lots of people are involved
in food distribution systems to the poor,
food banks and these kinds of things,
these are feel-good issues,
and I hope they're entry
points into the food system
and I support them for that reason.
You get people involved in this,
maybe realizing that
there are larger forces
that are causing this,
and maybe looking at
what in public health we
call upstream causes of it.
But there are lots of people
working on food waste.
I figure they don't need me.
- [Woman] Thanks for being here.
It's exciting to be face-to-face with you
after following you online for so long.
I'm just wondering, what you've seen
that's maybe been exciting to you
in terms of new mothers, pregnant women,
low-income women, specifically,
and healthy eating for babies,
knowing that if they start healthy,
the likelihood of continuing healthy--
- Well, there are lots of
people who are working on that
and lots of NGOs, and lots of groups.
It's not something I'm
personally interested,
that I'm personally involved in,
but I certainly support that
there are baby-friendly hospitals
and lots of efforts trying
to get women to breastfeed,
and some of them are successful,
and some of them more successful,
and I'm not sure what you're
really driving at here.
It's a good thing.
- [Woman] Hi, thank you for being here.
I was just hoping you could comment more
on the nature of the soda tax (mumbling)
contention of how this
tax could be higher burden
for (mumbling) low-income,
but we see how this tax
has been implemented in different ways
and I think Berkeley itself
has done it very creatively,
so I don't know if you could comment more
of like (mumbles).
- Different locations have decided to use
the tax money in different ways,
some of them more popular than others.
Berkeley, as I understand, is putting it
into child health and child health clinics
and it's actually doing
that, so that's great.
On it's a regressive tax
and it's hard on the poor,
my answer to that is that Type II Diabetes
is a regressive disease
and one of the reasons
why the tax passed in Berkeley, I think,
was because such a effort was made
to do community organizing around.
Do you know anybody who has diabetes?
Is anybody in your family have diabetes?
Do you know that the soda companies
are deliberately targeting
people of low-income?
And that kind of thing, a real
education around the issue.
So, I think the tax is a
phenomenal educational campaign,
a sort of an unexpected benefit,
even when the taxes don't pass
so the sales go down.
- [Woman] Hi, thank you
for being here today.
I have a question about
how we can get those
who are most affected by the industry
involved in this narratives,
and like you're talking about
how minorities or people
of color are most affected
by this industries, and also just access,
because just looking around this room,
and you say we should vote with our fork,
many people can't afford to do that,
so how to get more people involved
in this food movement?
- You do community organizing.
That's the basis of of everything.
If you want to bring a
large group of people
into this movement,
you've got to talk to them
and find out what they want.
You have to listen to them.
You need to try to work with them
to find out how you can help
them get what they want,
and expect it to take a long time.
It's not something where you can go in
and tell people what they ought to want.
I don't think that works very well,
though I'm greatly in favor
of community organizing.
It's hard, but it works.
- [Man] Thank you so much for your talk.
I just wanted to ask
you about your opinion
of the side effects of
carbon tax on food politics.
For one, generally,
corporations are centralized
so the miles that a product has to travel
would be also subject to that tax,
if the transportation is coming
from a fossil fuel source.
And as it looks that in the next 10 years,
that increasingly worldwide,
there'll be more and
more taxing of carbon,
I was wondering how the distinction that
Gerard Hastings makes between
businesses and industries,
between, say, a local socially-motivated,
also profit-motivated company versus a
you know, (mumbles)
responsibility investors
focused corporation on
how this centralization,
decentralization with taxing of distance
will make various foods more expensive
or local foods, say, less expensive.
- Thanks for asking that.
I rarely get asked questions
that I've never been asked before.
But you just won the prize
and I don't have the faintest idea.
(audience laughing)
But I will pay attention
to it from now on.
Thank you very much.
- [Woman] Okay, so if you
were to recruit nutritionists,
dieticians and food activists
to join your movement,
what could you ask us to do
to be apart of what you're doing?
- To pick an issue that you care about
and get to work on it.
There are plenty of them.
There are enormous numbers of food issues
that people are involved
in that they care about.
Pick the one that you
really feel passionate about
and get to work, and have fun with it.
Activism is fun.
Hello.
- Thank you so much for all
your work and coming here.
I wonder if you'd comment
on diet soda drinks.
- Oh, do I have to?
(audience laughing)
- I don't know some of these, Pepsi Cola,
and sort of trying to turn
themselves into health food
companies or at least change
their image in that regard.
- Well, I have rules about
eating and one of them
is never eat anything artificial,
so that completely excludes diet drinks
because they have artificial
sweeteners in them,
so they're off my radar.
I'm squirming about it
because I know lots of people
think that they're really
harmful and unhealthful.
I haven't seen that
evidence, I'm not convinced
that you do anything except
pee out all that stuff.
But I don't think they taste good,
and there's certainly no evidence
that they help people
maintain a healthy weight.
In fact, there's quite a bit of evidence
that people who consume diet sodas,
this is an interesting area where
you can tell who funded the study
by what its result is.
So if the study shows that diet drinks
help people lose weight,
and are really healthy,
the soda industry funded them.
And if the study comes out and says
people gain weight on diet sodas,
they were probably funded independently.
I don't know, I just don't want
to have anything to do with them,
so I'm not sure that's
very helpful, sorry.
And I don't know what
the tax people should do.
I think, probably the more important tax
would be a graded sugar tax,
like they're trying to do in Great Britain
and that would put a lot of pressure
on food companies to reduce sugar,
but it would also put
pressure on soda companies
to put more artificial
sweet in beverages out there
and I don't know.
I'm stuck on that one.
Is that it?
Thank you very much.
- [Woman] Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat techno music)